je me présente dominique grondin
directeur sportif et financier de
l'entreprise pardon l'entreprise pardon
a été créée par monsieur mais était-ce
peter en 1984 vous vous l'aurez compris
aujourd'hui on a 30 ans en trente années
d'existence
parsemer
parfois d'embûches mais de beaucoup de
créativité
ce qui a permis à la société
aujourd'hui
de compter 40 employés sur la réunion
et aux entier nous avons vis boutique su
à lille
2 aux antilles une à maurice une à
mayotte mayotte c'est il s'agit d'un
revendeur et nous sommes en train de
développer la métropole au travers de
corner et de revente dans des commerces
pardon recherche pour le secteur nord
une vendeuse ou un vendeur la ville
d'affectation sera sainte clotilde cette
personne devrait être impliqué
souriante savoir accueillir le client
savoir conseiller
maîtriser les encaissements en plus de
toutes ces qualités le vendeur la
vendeuse qui sera retenu devra respecter
la charpente c'est à dire venir
travailler dans la bonne humeur
s'habiller en pardon adopter une allure
général dynamique et décalé par rapport
aux vendeurs des autres enseignes donc
si vous vous reconnaissez dans ce profil
envoyez nous votre candidature
je vois des sandales ajusté j'habite à
cet objet aux solutions pour passer mon
permis je recherche un emploi dans la vo
peu importe mon pâtissier ou
en magasin j'aimerais bien travailler
dans la zone est du lot rodez mais
toujours obtenu mon cap et du commerce
aussi appelé m'a permis de mieux
connaître tout l'été de la montre et
ainsi avoir une bonne relation avec la
clientèle
j'ai pu acquérir une expérience de la
vente en bourse ou pâtissent clé
prêt-à-porter et mêmes
en grande surface c'est ma candidature
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas long
je m'appelle clairement eu c'est vrai
j'ai 24 ans je demeure à bois nèfles
saint paul et le métier que je recherche
et hôtesses d'accueil tels que patrice
dans la zone ouest je suis actuellement
en train de passer mon permis au niveau
de mes espérances j'ai effectué une
mission palais de la source du conseil
général de saint denis
j'ai orienté le public j'ai les
renseigner j'ai pris leur rendez vous et
je les fais d'accueil pour eux je suis
dynamique ponctuelles souriante
n'hésitez pas à m'appeler
bonjour je m'appelle fredrik kata et
l'habitat saint pierre puis suivre
précisément la ravine des cabris je vais
cherche un métier de chauffeur livreur
tu as tout lire j'ai le pmi s'étant plus
que ces mots et j'ai un véhicule
j'ai travaillé dans des centres
politiquement laverie 600 au tampon et
même le confort j'ai le niveau bep vente
le niveau bas des pentes et bétonne pour
toutes à tous surtout avec de la
dentelle j'ai déjà le premier reproche
au maire broche la timidité maintenant
c'est fini j'ai un baiser du montage la
réception des marchandises à libre ezzor
je suis quelqu'un de sérieux motivé aime
le travail en équipe et surtout produire
en toute sécurité voilà je me suis
présenté je suis disponible
il attend votre appel avec impatience
contactez nous sur notre page facebook
www.facebook.com slash 9 7 4 tv ou par
téléphone 02 100 62 92 37 60
de 7 4 cv autre émission au service de
l'emploi à la réunion